[Musique]
messieurs je pense que nous aurons à
parler d'un certain nombre de choses sur
des objets fort important
et le mieux que nous ayons à faire à mon
sens c'est d'organiser notre entretien
notre conférence
c'est pourquoi je m'en vais tout
simplement pour commencer demandé à ceux
d'entre vous qui ont des questions
déterminé à poser d'avoir l'obligeance
de se lever et de m'en donner dès à
présent connaissance de façon que nous
mettions nos affaires en or alors je
vous en prie messieurs ceux d'entre vous
qui ont quelques questions à me poser je
leur demande de me les poser dès à
présent
sur le président quelle est la position
de la france à l'égard des gouvernements
qui viennent de reconnaître le gpr oui
pensez vous qu'on peut éviter un conflit
mondial au sujet de l'allemagne et de
berlin et dans quelles conditions est
par ailleurs s cause estimé que la
reprise des essais nucléaires par
l'union soviétique rend la recherche
d'une solution pacifique plus difficile
moins difficiles ou bien n'y a pas
énormément d'importance ou bien vous en
prie monsieur le président
de gaulle juste il souhaitable ou
opportun qu'un acte internationale
viennent consacrer le tracé actuel des
frontières allemandes et en garantir le
respect bien et encore vous en prie
passion de maintenir la base de bizerte
au service des deux défenses occidental
avez vous pris en considération la
possibilité de négocier la cession aux
forces de l'otan
bien
l'action des lots et du haut katanga est
elle conforme au droit à
l'autodétermination
oui
fort bien je suis président il ya
quelques semaines un dîner à l'elysée
vous avez dit aux parlementaires pour
lire vous débarrasser de la question
algérienne avant la fin de cette année
est ce vous débarrassez comment résoudre
le problème algérien bien là
et encore
est
ce que le général de gaulle approuvent
la décision britannique d'adhérer au
marché commun
et encore monsieur le président ce que
vous estimez estimez-vous plus
exactement que l'armée a surmonté la
crise issue du 22 avril vient
et pour cela le président oui
je vous en prie monsieur le président
qu'est ce que c'est la position
française en ce qui concerne la
proposition anglo american sur la
suspension des essais nucléaires en
atmosphère bien celle ci se ramène à ce
que nous avons entendu déjà je vous en
prie
prie du prochain contingent bien et puis
le mix si vous permettez
estimez-vous que devant le
mécontentement actuel renaissant des
milieux agricoles il y ait lieu
d'envisager une modification de la
politique d'ensemble de votre
gouvernement ont vue d'accélérer la
réforme et la modernisation des
structures bien
alors
alors je vois que tous en fait un
ensemble du reste très cohérent et dont
je dois vous dire qu'il ne me surprend
pas il y à ce qui se rapporte sous une
forme ou sous une autre à la situation
internationale actuelle à l'occasion de
la faire de berlin et de tout ce qui s'y
rapporte c'est un premier sujet il ya
naturellement là furent algérienne à
divers égards
sony d'un autre il y à la question de
bizerte c'en est un troisième est alors
il yal'affaire agricole
et puis alors quelques annexes
concernant l'armée
concernant les essais nucléaires ou leur
suspension
et ainsi de suite eh bien nous allons
aborder ces sujets les uns après les
autres nous allons commencer si vous
voulez bien par le quai la question
extérieur la plus importante celle que
vous avez bien voulu me poser monsieur
le premier au sujet de la sphère de
berlin je vais vous demander de
renouveler votre question et j'y
répondrai
un conflit mondial au sujet de
l'allemagne et de berlin peut-être évité
et dans quelles conditions
et ma question connexe étaient
concernées les essais nucléaires
soviétiques
je voudrais demander si vous estimiez
que ses rangs des la recherche de la
paix plus difficile moins difficile ou
bien n'y avait pas énormément
d'importance dans ce sens
on peut en effet se demander
pourquoi les soviets
ont pris tout à coup
le prétexte de berlin
pour exiger que le statut de la ville
soit changée du grès ou de force
on peut se demander aussi
pourquoi
cette situation de vérins qui leur
paraît tolérable depuis 16 ans et qu'ils
ont d'eux m o rganisée institué avec les
états unis et la grande bretagne à la
réunion de postdam où la france
d'ailleurs n'était pas
pourquoi cette situation leur paraît
tout à coup intolérable
on peut se demander pourquoi ils
assortissent tout à coup leur exigence
de menaces épouvantable
on peut se demander s'il ya quelqu'un
qui croit vraiment
qu'il y est un danger de la part de la
république fédérale allemande telle
qu'elle est
vis-à-vis de la russie actuelle
et on peut se demander enfin s'il ya
vraiment un soviétique qui le croit
puisque
le kremlin des cas
qu'il est en mesure d'écraser totalement
immédiatement sous des bombes
qui valent paraît-il 100 millions de
tonnes d'explosifs
quiconque les vrais la main sur le monde
communiste
en vérité
il y a dans sept
camps ce tumulte
de
l'imprécation
et de sommation
organisé par les soviets
quelque chose de tellement arbitraire et
tellement artificielle
qu'on ait conduit à
l'attribuer
ou bien
aux déchaînements prémédité d'ambition
frénétique
ou bien un dérivatif
à de grandes difficultés
cette deuxième hypothèse
me paraît d'autant plus plausible
qu'en dépit et des contraintes
de l' isolement
et
des actes de force
dans lequel régime lesquels régime
communiste enferme les pays qui sont
sous son joug
et malgré
certaines
réussites collectives qu'il a réalisés
en présent sur la substance de ces
sujets
en fait
ces lacunes ces défaillances
ces échecs interne et par dessus tout
son caractère
l'écrasement inhumain
sont
ressentis
de plus en plus
par des élites cdma ce
qu'il est de plus en plus malaisé de
leurrer et de courbet
et puis aussi
et satellite
que le régime soviétique
tient sous sa loi
éprouvent
de plus en plus dans leur sentiment
national
ce qu'il y à de cruelles dans l'annexion
qu'ils ont subi
alors
on comprend que dans ces conditions
les soviets
considère que la sphère de berlin
peut-être une occasion appropriée pour
se donner le change et pour le donner
aux autres est en effet là où berlin est
situé il leur est
relativement facile
de faire des manifestations
sur place et les mesures
de contraintes qu'ils prennent
on peut entraîne pour eux et des risques
limités
et puis peuvent penser
que les états unis lors de terre et la
france
se laisseront glissé à quelques
découragement à quelques résignation
et qu ainsi le recul de ces trois
puissances amènera un coup grave pour
l'alliance atlantique que par dessus
tout devant le monde entier
il apparaîtra
que le régime
totalitaire le camp totalitaire devant
un occident incertain est divisée est
décidément le plus fort
or justement ce n'est pas vrai
assurément
les soviets et dispose
d'armements nucléaires
terrible
mais les occidentaux en ont aussi de
formidables
si le conflit mondial devait éclater
la mise en oeuvre des forces de
destruction
entraînerait en particulier sans aucun
doute le bouleversement complet de la
russie
et des pays
qui sont en proie au communisme
à quoi bon
régner sur des morts
et puis du reste le règne serait
terminée aussi
parce que dans ce désastre
l'armature serait brisée l'armature d'un
régime qui ne tient qu'en vertu d'un
appareil d'autorité
d'activité
et de police
rigidement planifier et implacablement
imposer cela d'ailleurs les dirigeants
soviétiques le savent
malgré tout leurs ventes hardys
alors les puissances occidentales
n'ont aucune raison
de ne pas considérer
avec un oeil claire
et un choeur ferme
les manifestations soviétique
il est vrai je le répète
que localement à berlin
l'action de forces qui seraient engagées
pourraient provoquer pourrait procurer
aux soviets
quelques avantages parce que il sera
évidemment difficile aux puissances
occidentales d'agir en partant de loin
sur le sol et dans le ciel de l'ancienne
capitale allemande
mais
les occidentaux pourraient fort bien
riposter
sur des mers et dans des ciels du monde
que parcours des navires ou les avions
soviétiques qui aussi serait loin de
leurs bases
il y aurait alors un échange de mauvais
procédés
qui
ne se termineraient sans doute pas au
bénéfice des soviets
bref
si ceux ci
veulent par la force
réduire les positions et coupé les
communications
des alliés à berlin
les alliés doivent par la force
maintenir leur position et maintenir
leur communication
assurément de fil en aiguille comme on
dit et si tout cela fait multiplier les
actes hostiles des soviets acte
auxquelles il faudrait répondre
on pourrait en venir
à la guerre générale
mais alors
c'est que les soviets il aurait
délibérément voulue
et dans ce cas tout recul préalable de
l'occident
n'aurait servi qu'à l'affaiblir et à le
diviser
et sans empêcher l'échéance
un certain point de menaces de la part
d'un impérialisme ambitieux
tour recul
a pour effet de surexcités l'agresseur
de le pousser à redoubler sa pression
et finalement
facilite et rate son assaut
au total
actuellement
les puissances occidentales
n'ont pas de meilleur moyen de servir la
paix du monde
que de rester droite et ferme
est ce que ça veut dire que pour
toujours les deux camps devront
s'opposer
ce n'est pas du tout ce que pense la
france
parce que ce serait vraiment très bête
et que ce serait vraiment très cher
si le conflit mondial doit éclater
alors
le progrès mécanique moderne
aura abouti à la mort
sinon c'est la paix qu'il faut tenter de
faire
que les soviets
cessent de menacer
qu'il aide
la détente à s'établir au lieu de
l'empêcher
qu'il favorise une atmosphère
international pacifique
dans dix qui la rendent étouffante
alors il sera possible aux trois
puissance de l'occident
d'étudier avec eux tous les problèmes du
monde et notamment
celui de l'allemagne
et dans ce cas on pourrait compter
que la france
ménagerait des solutions
c'est qu'en effet la france qui pour sa
part n'est pas disposé à céder
aux menaces de lempire totalitaire
la france garde cependant sincère
et profonde son amitié pour les pays
qui vivent dans cet empire
et puis
la france croit
que la civilisation moderne
n'a d'avenir
que par l'entente
et puis la coopération et enfin l'osmose
des pays qui l'ont fait et qu'ils
continuent de la faire
qu'ils ont répandu sur la terre et qui
continue de me répandre
et avant tout
de tous les peuples européens
voilà ce que je puis vous répondre
monsieur
quant à la seconde question à son
corollaire de la première que me vais
poser
au sujet des expériences atomiques
je vous répondrai simplement ceci
la france c'est qu'une conférence est
engagée depuis longtemps à genève entre
les trois états qui ont des armements
atomiques énorme
cette conférence nous est toujours
apparu comme devant faire partie d'un
ensemble qui s'appelle le désarmement et
plus particulièrement le désarmement
atomique
pour tous ceux qui effectivement
tendrait au désarmement atomique la
france coopérerait sans aucun doute
voilà ce que je peux vous dire pour le
moment
quelqu'un m'a parlé de l'algérie et même
plusieurs je serais heureux qu'on me
renouvelle comme répète les questions
qui étaient déposées
quelle est la position de la france à
l'égard des gouvernements qui ont
reconnu le gp a bien il y avait une
autre question sur l'ensemble de la
question je vous en prie
oui
et enfin madame vous aviez demandé
quelque chose sur la question algérienne
comment vous voulez vous débarrasser de
la question algérienne avant la fin de
cette année parfaitement en donnant
l'indépendance à l'algérie
bien
bon s'il jarry sur le ca atteint oui
bien bien bien voilà alors à tout cela
je m'en vais répondre
je vous avais plutôt répété
que notre conception pour l'algérie
je le répète
est complètement différente
de celle que nous y avons pratiqué
depuis la conquête que nous y avions
pratiqué depuis la conquête et cela
parce que les conditions
française algérienne et mondial de 7 à
flers ont elles-mêmes complètement
changé
notre objectif n'est pas du tout
de garder
la
responsabilité politique
administrative économique de l'algérie
cette politique là si elle a pu en de
tout autre temps
être peut-être peut-être valable
aujourd'hui elle serait vaine et
anachronique
et nous le croyons pas du tout
que l'intérêt que l'honneur que l'avenir
de la france
soient liés
au maintien
à l'époque où nous sommes de sa
domination sur des populations dans la
grande majorité ne fait pas partie de
son peuple et que tous portent et
portera de plus en plus à s'affranchir
et à sa part tenir
cela il faut le comprendre et il faut la
voir dans l'esprit quand on épie l'aube
sur la pensée du chef de l'état dans la
matière
encore une fois
nous sommes un pays en pleine révolution
qui sait
que la source de la prospérité
et de la puissance c'est son propre
développement
qui a besoin de ses moyens chez lui pour
y parvenir
et qui n'entend pas les engouffré
indéfiniment dans des tâches sans issue
bref
le métier d'être les processeurs et les
nourrisseurs de cette région
nous ne tenons pas du tout
bien entendu nous n'excluons pas que ce
dégagement
aboutissent à une coopération comme cela
a eu lieu ailleurs
mais cette coopération pour désirable
qu'elle nous paraissent et surtout dans
l'ordre du sentiment
cette coopération nous est nullement
nécessaire
nous nous tenons que dans la mesure
où elle comporterait
échanges
et compréhension
alors
le problème algérien se ramène pour nous
à trois termes essentiels
l'institution d'un état algérien
les rapports de la france avec cet état
et comme vous l'avez
proposer monsieur
l'avenir du sahara
l'institution d'un état algérien
un tel état d'où peut-il sortir
normalement il ne peut sortir que de
l'autodétermination
c'est à dire du suffrage des habitants
parce qu'il n'existe pas de légitimité
de souveraineté algérienne
antérieure à la conquête est acquis en
puissant remettre comme on l'a fait en
tunisie
ou au maroc
et cette autodétermination cela veut
dire un référendum
qui instituera l'état algérien et puis
ensuite des élections d'où sortira le
gouvernement définitif
mais nous ne voulons pas que la libre
disposition au cas où elle aurait lieu
que la libre disposition que la libre
disposition je dis bien
procède directement de l'autorité
française
car alors nous serions encore accrocher
vainement
alors que ce dont il s'agit c'est du
dégagement
dans ces conditions
ce n'est qu'un pouvoir
provisoire algérien
qui peut mener le pays à
l'autodétermination et aux élections
encore faut-il bien sûr que ce pouvoir
est assez de consistance et assez
d'audience
et aussi qu'ils se soient mis en accord
avec nous sur les conditions de
l'opération
on avait pu imaginer peut-être peut-on
encore
imaginer que le fln
or vu que tous les combats et les
attentats aient cessées
ferait partie d'un tel organisme
et d'ailleurs c'était là à des objets
principaux des conversations que nous
avons tenté d'engager et avec ses
représentants
faute que cela puisse se faire
il n'y a pas d'autre source concevable
pour l'exécutif algérien
que l'ensemble des élus
et cet exécutif sa tâche immédiate
serait de conduire le pays
encore une fois au référendum et aux
élections
avec sans doute
la mise à sa disposition
d'une force d'ordre local
si à la longue
et en définitive
malgré
ce que propose la france et ce qu'elle
compte encore proposé
on ne pouvait pas
aboutir
à ce que des algériens
veuille puisse
conduire l'algérie
à sa propre décision
alors il faudrait bien que nous en
tirions les conséquences
et
en effet
pour la france
la situation actuelle en algérie ne peut
pas durer toujours
et d'autre part le succès de nos armes
sur le terrain
qui nous assure l'entière liberté de
notre décision et de nos mouvements
nous sommes pas certains que la
situation internationale
nous l'aller sera gardée entière
indéfiniment
c'est pourquoi dans l'hypothèse que je
dis
ne serions amenés à regrouper dans une
région déterminée
les algériens de souche européenne et
ceux des musulmans qui voudraient rester
avec la france
après on y verrait sans doute plus clair
d'autant plus que parmi ces éléments
ceux qui exprimeraient lequin
exprimerait lé désir
serait
amenée dans la métropole
où l'on implantation et leur situation
future
doive être réglé incessamment
et quant aux territoires que nous
laisserions à eux mêmes
il va de soi que les crédits de
fonctionnement
et d'investissement qui leur sont à
présent consacré seraient bloqués
d'autres que nous prendrait aurait à
répondre de la vie des populations
il y à la sphère du sahara
pour ce qui est du sahara
notre ligne de conduite c'est celle qui
sauvegarde de nos intérêts et qui tient
compte des réalités
quelles sont nos intérêts
nos intérêts c'est la libre exploitation
du pétrole et du gaz que nous avons
découvert ou que nous découvririons
c'est la disposition de terrains
d'aviation
et de droit de circulation pour nos
communications et que l'afrique noire
les réalités
les réalité c'est que il n'ya pas un
seul algérien je le sais
qu'ils ne pensent que le sahara doit
faire partie de l'algérie
et qu'il n'y aurait pas un seul
gouvernement algérien quelle que soit
son orientation par rapport à la france
qui ne doit vraiment revendiquer sans
relâche la souveraineté algérienne sur
le sahara
et puis enfin
le fait que si un état algérien est
institué et qu'il est associé à la
france
la grande majorité des populations
sahariennes
tendront à s'y rattachent et même si
elles ne l'ont pas explicitement
réclamée d'avant
c'est dire
que dans le débat franco algérien
qu'il sera nîmes avec le fn
ou qu'ils s'engagent
avec un autre organisme représentatif
celui-là des élus
la question de la souveraineté du sahara
n'a pas être considérés plutôt moins
elle ne l'est pas par la france
ça peut servir de slogans de panneaux
pour une propagande
en ce qui concerne la france c'est un
coup d'épée dans l'eau
mais ce qui nous intéresse
c'est que ils sortent de ces
accords s'ils doivent se produire
une association qui sauvegardent nos
intérêts
si ni la sauvegarde dit l'association
ne sont possibles du côté algérien bien
il nous faudra de toutes ces pierres et
de toutes ces sables de ces simples
faire quelque chose de particulier
aussi longtemps et pour autant que pour
en nous
la compagnie ne sera pas supérieure à la
vente âge
de toute façon bien entendu il faudra
que les populations algériennes soient
consultés sur leur sort
et dans des conditions conformes
à leur dispersion et à leur diversité
ces populations algériennes
étant donné que le sahara
figurez vous c'est un désert
elles sont en nombre infime est
rarissime
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur tout
cet ensemble algérien
on a parlé de bizerte voudrais savoir
qu'il avait fait
vous en prie étant donné votre
préoccupation de maintenir la base de
bizerte au service de la défense de
défense occidental avez vous pris en
considération la possibilité de négocier
sa session aux forces de l'otan
bizarre tu n'as jamais été couvert par
l'otan
et je ne crois pas que be that le sera
jamais
ce n'est pas dans la nature de
l'organisation dont vous parlez
le fait est que quand on veut se faire
un jugement
qui ne soit pas de parti pris sur cette
affaire de bizerte
moi je recommande qu'on regarde la carte
alors on voit bizerte occupant une
situation
exceptionnelle
là où la méditerranée se resserre
entre ces deux bassins l'oriental et
l'occidental
les pays qui bordent le second c'est à
dire l'occidentale
pour eux
il y a la perspective
d'une agression qui viendrait de l'autre
c'est à dire de l'oriental
et ils ne peuvent pas ne pas l'envisager
d'autant plus que la situation du monde
est dominé tous les jours à tous les
instants par la perspective d'une guerre
que l'est déclencherait contre l'ouest
et puis sur la carte il faut regarder
que se trouve la france
la france qui en cas d'intervention
adverse dans ses parages
seraient
intéressés d'une manière vitale à ce
qu'il arriverait militairement et
politiquement
aux riverains qui sont proches de son
territoire
la france qui serait de toute manière
impliqué d'une manière directe dans la
défense des deux bords de la
méditerranée
alors quand on a considéré ces réalités
là
on comprend que la france ne veuille pas
et ne puisse pas dans la situation du
monde telle qu'elle est
exposée s'exposer elles mêmes exposées
l'europe exposé le monde libre à
l'éventualité d'une saisie de bizerte
par des forces hostiles
voilà pourquoi la france a établi une
base à bizerte
cette base est calé il ya maintenu
jusqu'aux derniers événements la
garnison minimum indispensable pour
éviter que bizerte depuis cette reprise
par un coup de main
cette base
là rien qui menace n'est qu'ils fassent
pression
sur la tunisie elle est entièrement
tourné vers la mer et pas du tout vers
l'extérieur
au milieu des installations il ya deux
villes
bizerte et menzel bourguiba qui étaient
administrés normalement par les
tunisiens est occupée par leurs troupes
l'arsenal est en pleine ville tunisienne
il ya des milliers de tunisiens qui
avant les événements travaillait dans
l'arsenal ou bien sur les terrains
militaires
et le goulet qui fait communiquer la
base avec la mère
était tenu par les tunisiens
quand nous avons en 1954 quand la france
a de sa propre initiative
conclues avec le gouvernement beylical
le traité qui remplaçait le protectorat
quand elle a reconnu en 1956
l'indépendance de la tunisie et quand
j'ai moi-même en 1958 prescrit le
retrait de toutes les forces françaises
qui se trouvait encore dans ce pays
n'avons jamais un seul moment laissé de
doute dans l'esprit des tunisiens que
tout en prenant à leur égard cette voix
qui était bien celle de l'amitié
nous comptions continuer à utiliser la
base de bizerte tant que le danger
mondial serait ce qu il est
naturellement cela ne nous empêchait pas
de proposer aux tunisiens comme nous le
faisons constamment
de régler avec nous les conditions
d'utilisation de cette base
et nous laurent remettions au fur à
mesure
toutes espèces d'installation et de
casernes qui n'étaient pas
indispensables à l'emploi éventuelle des
organisations
et par dessus tout nous entretenions
avec la tunisie tout un ensemble de
rapports
politiques
économiques
culturels humains dans le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il n'était pas son
détriment
du côté de tunis
nous pouvions penser
que tout en proclamant la souveraineté
de la tunisie sur bizerte souveraineté
qui n'a jamais été contesté en principe
du côté français qui ne l'est pas
et tout en déclarant qu'il faudrait
qu'un jour soit négocier le retrait des
troupes françaises
on comprenait
que la situation générale ne comportait
pas actuellement ces tissus
et les échanges de lettres qui a eu lieu
le 10 et juin 1958 entre mon
gouvernement est celui de tunis et qui a
réglé ce retrait des forces françaises
dont je parlais tout à l'heure c'était
dangereux lettre excepté bizerte ce
retrait est réservée explicitement ce
cas
on pourrait donc croire encore une fois
du côté français
que c'était
une sorte d'engagement à l'expectative
et à la temporisation
quand le président de la république
tunisienne a été reçu par moi-même à
rambouillet le 27 février dernier
et que la question de bizerte est venue
dans nos entretiens
je leur ai dis de la façon la plus nette
que la situation étant ce qu'elle était
la france ne pouvait et ne voulait pas
acquitté bizerte
et je dois dire qu'il m'a paru s'en
accommoder
et du reste après nos conversations il
s'est répandu en déclarations amicales à
notre égard
et même il a dit à plusieurs reprises
que pour le maghreb la question
essentielle c'est ed règlement de la
question de la sphère algérienne est
temps que ça n'aurait pas abouti ne
poserait pas lui la question de vision
pour ne pas ajouter à la complication
des choses
alors des raisons qui tiennent
probablement
ce qui se passe dans l'univers arabe
la république tunisienne a tout à coup
changé de ton et de chansons
ça a été les menaces et puis les sommes
nation et puis l'agression il faut dire
que dans les entretiens de rambouillet
le président de la république tunisienne
avait réclamé au sahara une
rectification de frontières en faveur de
la tunisie et aux dépens de l'algérie
cette rectification de frontières devant
ménages est en quelque sorte un accès
futur à la tunisie vers le sahara et du
reste monsieur bourguiba ne cachait pas
que c'était là qu'une étape et qui
visait au plus profond du désert la
région d'être gelé où se trouve
commencer
d'importants gisements de pétrole
je remarque en passant que la région
d'el geneina j'ai jamais été habité par
qui que ce soit avant que les français
n'y est placé leur implantation et leur
recherche
mais enfin il y avait là un signe de
plus de cet intérêt passionné et soudain
qui est portée maintenant par d'autres
que des nomades très clairsemés des
explorateurs épisodique de grottes où
les touristes passagers à au désert
saharien
mai
j'ajoute que il semblait tout se passait
comme si
la décision amical que mon gouvernement
avait prise en 1958 à l'égard de la
tunisie
de
faire aboutir l'oléoduc des dégelées en
tunisie au lieu de le diriger sur
l'algérie comme celui d'hassi messaoud
ce qui procurait à l'état tunisien en
définitive aux frais de la france des
redevances qui n'est pas négligeable
eh bien ça servait comme d'un titre à
l'état tunisien pour réclamer la source
du pactole
nous avons fait connaître à l'époque car
monsieur bourguiba que du moment que
nous étions en train d'aider à naître un
état algérien qui pourrait pas ne pas
être intéressé au premier chef par le ca
et pendant que nous étions en train
aussi
de consacrer dans le désert beaucoup
d'initiés de nos initiatives et beaucoup
de nos investissements
et mais nous n'allions pas
inconsidérément
découper les pierres et des sables leur
souveraineté et la distribuer en tranche
la question du chat ne pouvait pas être
étudier normalement est réglé à ce
moment là avec la tunisie
alors je le répète c'est un succès pas
alors qu'il y a eu
cette agression
tunisienne d'une part sur notre
territoire au ca et d'autre part sur nos
installations à bizerte
et en même temps il y avait toutes
sortes de
séquestration de spoliation et
d'humiliation à l'égard d'un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes qui vivent en
tunisie
dans ces conditions nous avions rien
d'autre à faire et nous n'avons rien
fait d'autre que de maintenir
l'intégrité de notre territoire au
sahara
il y aurait établir
n'utilisa les conditions d'utilisation
de la base du blizzard
et bien sûr nous le ferons encore le cas
échéant
mais nous ne cessons pas depuis
longtemps et encore récemment
d'inviter le gouvernement tunisien à
conclure avec nous d'abord un modus
vivendi pour blizzard et ensuite
d'entamer des négociations sur les
conditions d'utilisation de la base dans
la période dangereuse que court le mende
actuellement
alors on me dit vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure que y avait eu une discussion
et le vote d'une motion par
l'organisation des nations dites unis
je ne crois pas nécessaire de
d'indiquer qu' étant donné la façon dont
cette organisation est maintenant
composé
et aussi les courants et ne frénétique
ou chimérique qui l'agitent
et aussi le fait qu'elle est en
contradiction en violation permanente de
sa propre charte nous ne l'ont pas lui
reconnaître aucune espèce de droit
d'arbitrage ni de juridiction
quand tous les mots qu'on ya a prodigué
sur le sujet
ce seront évanouie après tant et tant
d'autres il restera les réalités
puisse tunis
en tenir compte
pour régler sont retrouvés avec paris un
arrangement
qui soit conforme au bon sens
c'est là le souhait de la france
quelqu'un m'a parlé de notre agriculture
et des mouvements qui s'y produisaient
ou qu'ils risquaient de s'y produire
n'est-il pas vrai voulez-vous me répéter
votre question oui monsieur le président
je m'excuse d'ailleurs de rompre l'unité
de cette conférence en parle en
agriculture les tout se tient l'année
les les milieux agricoles sans avoir
pris conscience de leur retard par
rapport au secteur en expansion dans
l'économie de son côté votre
gouvernement semble avoir pris
conscience également de ces retards
vis-à-vis du secteur agricole il a pris
un certain nombre de mesures non
négligeable mais c'est un fait qui n'ont
pas donné satisfaction aux bénéficiaires
dans ces conditions monsieur le
président envisagez-vous de repenser
l'ensemble de la politique agricole du
gouvernement en vue d'accélérer les
rythmes de modernisation d'agriculture
et d'intégration du secteur agricole non
seulement dans l'économie mais dans la
vie culturelle technique et social du
pays oui ce qui se passe vous avez
raison de l'évoquer
ce qui se passe c'est que l'agriculture
française se trouve à son tour
saisi
par les facteurs de transformation
qui domine notre époque
en ce qui la concerne
il s'agit de la nécessité
d'adapter ses structures et ses
organisations
aux conditions
de la qualité
et du rendement et de la concurrence
et puis alors il y à là comme partout
une poussée générale vers un meilleur
niveau de vie
vers une sécurité sociale mieux assurée
vers une instruction plus complète
bref
l'agriculture est saisi par l'évolution
comme
l'industrie l'est
et du reste
se développe en conséquence je parle de
l'industrie
et comme il faudra bien que le commerce
en fassent autant
cette évolution
indispensable de l'agriculture
c'est son intérêt
et c'est aussi l'intérêt du pays c'est
surtout l'intérêt du pays
qui veut que cette branche si importante
ne soit pas comme on dit à la traîne et
qu'elle soit un élément équilibré
moderne de son activité
son activité économique
alors
naturellement ce sujet là
hélène ceux qui occupent principalement
l'état son chef
et son gouvernement
qui veulent
que l'intérêt national profite
de ce mouvement
qui se fait jour pour le progrès
et pour la rénovation parmi nos ruraux
la politique valable
pour la collectivité française dans
cette affaire
c'est celle qui pousse et qui est
l'agriculture à se transformer
c'est
le grand effort d'orientation
et d'équipements
qui a été commencé entamée l'année
dernière
par les pouvoirs publics sur une échelle
qui ne jamais
été vu
ça consiste pour l'état
a déterminé les exploitations
à adopter des structures des dimensions
des productions qui puisse les rendre
tout rentable
ça consiste à amener les agriculteurs
eux-mêmes à s'organiser
à organiser leur marché pour acheter et
pour vendre en limitant les
intermédiaires
à établir les installations qui
permettent de conserver
et de
conditionner les produits de façon à
pouvoir les offrir au moment opportun et
sous une forme choisie
et puis aussi
amener les agriculteurs à prendre à leur
compte à prendre eux mêmes ou attribuer
un personnel qui soit le lors une large
part des industries et des commerces qui
exploite les fruits de la terre
l'effort de l'état consiste aussi
à faciliter l'implantation
d'activités diverses dans les régions
agricoles
de telle manière que ceux qui n'ont sont
en trop dans la profession en
particulier des jeunes à cause de la
mécanisation
puisse s'employer sans quitter
nécessairement le pays
également assuré sur place
l'instruction de la jeunesse
une instruction qui vaille celle qu'ont
d'ailleurs
de telle sorte que un jeune homme une
jeune fille veut ou ne peut pas rester
comme on dit à la terre est bien trouve
des chances égales à celles des autres
améliorer aussi certainement
la situation des agriculteurs en ce qui
concerne la sécurité sociale les
allocations familiales la retraite des
vieux
et poursuivre
poursuivre
l'équipement le programme d'équipement
des campagnes pour l'eau pour les
logements pour les écoles pour les
hôpitaux pour les chemins et cetera
voilà qui est valable et constructif
encore une fois c'est cette politique là
qui est en oeuvre depuis l'année
dernière
et que les pouvoirs publics doivent
poursuivre
bien sûr dans la mesure
où dans d'autres domaines
cela leur est possible compte tenu de l'
équilibre général
qu'est-ce que l'agriculture à faire dans
cette période dure de sa propre
gestation c'est pas évidemment de se
livrer à des démagogies partisane qui la
conduirait qu'ils conduiraient le pays a
rien qu'à des malheurs
il s'agit qu'elles s'organisent elles
mêmes pour sa propre évolution
du reste je dois dire que je constate
souvent
et que je sais
qu'à cet égard
il y a beaucoup de choses qu'elle fait
déjà
et qu'elle projette de faire
c'est une
très grande tâche nationale
et j'ai confiance dans les pouvoirs
publics et dans les agriculteurs
français pour que cette tâche là soit
mené à bien
quelqu'un m'avait demandé quelque chose
encore sur d'autres sujets
corrélatif à cela la décision de la
grande-bretagne d'adhérer au marché
comme vous l'a prouvé hors de tout temps
les les participants au marché commun
qu'ils sont six
ont souhaité
que d'autres et en particulier la grande
bretagne
se joignent au traité de rome
qu'ils en assument les obligations et
qui je pense qu'ils en reçoivent les
avantages
nous savons très bien quelle est la
complexité du problème
mais il semble que tous portent
maintenant à l'aborder
et pour ma part je n'ai qu'à m'en
féliciter non seulement au point de vue
de mon pays mais je crois aussi au point
de vue de l'europe et du même coup au
point de vue du monde
et bien mesdames messieurs je voulais à
dire quelques mots pour conclure si vous
voulez bien
en réalité la france
est engagée
dans un effort
de
rénovation de renouvellement plus grand
qu aucun de ceux qu'elle s'est jamais
imposé
elle poursuit
son essor
économique
technique social
elle multiplie sa jeunesse
et elle y développe l'instruction
elle achève outre-mer
sa tâche pénible de décolonisation
elle reprend son poids international
elle modernise ses moyens de défense
nous sommes ne peut pas aller ne va pas
sans difficulté sans secousse
parce que la faire elle même est très
dur
et puis nous revenons de très loin
et puis
tout ce qu'il y a de parti pris
l'intérêt particulier de passion de
routine se trouve inévitablement
mise en cause
comme
l'état a subi de graves crises depuis
longtemps
et a subi un longue abaissement
il advient que
dans les corps qui le servent
il y ait des négligences et des
défaillances
mamie eu des dissidences
comme
les libertés la liberté est maintenu
dans tous les domaines
politiques presse
syndicats
les doléances et critique les
revendications se donne et aimant
carrière
comme
les clandés rang qu ancienne et nouvelle
ce aussi du pessimisme foncier
ce enfin de l'obéissance à l'étranger
totalitaires
comme tous ces clans sajid simultanément
à propos de tous les sujets
on sent que fois dans l'air
quelque chose comme des entreprises
de découragement public
mais tout ça ce n'est qu'une écume
flottant sur les profondeurs
quiconque chez nous et odeurs a les yeux
ouverts
et l'oreille attentive
se rend à l'évidence de notre progrès
national
alors
devant cette france qui est stable et
solide
[Musique]
s'affiche plus virulente que jamais
maintenant
les prétentions soviétique devant la
france et devant le monde
on peut constater que
notre pays
se montrent
également ferme et serein
vis-à-vis du trouble du dehors
sans doute entre-t-il dans son attitude
lui dès
que le prétexte pris par les soviets
pour leur manifestation
est tellement dérisoire par rapport aux
malheurs qu'il risque de déclencher
qui n'iront pas aux extrémités qu'il
détruirait de même
tandis qu'il râle aja les autres
et puis
notre peuple
par instinct et par expérience
juge
que
c'est servir la paix du monde
que de ne pas reculer devant ceux qui la
menacent
d'autre part
il pense
que des hommes libres comme nous le
sommes en france
ne doivent pas laisser à servir
ceux qui veulent le demeurer
mais
en même temps
notre peuple croit
qu un pays
sûr de lui-même
comme est le nôtre
doit
se tenir prêts
aux ententes
au rapprochement aux efforts en commun
que les grands états des deux côtés
seront obligés d'entreprendre
à moins que la catastrophe n'éclate
et
notre peuple pense que dans ce cas
il pourra rendre un service signalé à
l'univers
quelle est la france d'aujourd'hui
on peut déplorer
que ces moyens relatifs
ne soit pas égaux
à ceux qui furent lyciens en d'autres
périodes de son histoire
ont bien souvent
je puis le dire
j'en aurai et prouvez moi même
le chagrin et inconvénients
mais
il n'en reste pas moins
que dès à présent
pour peu que les français persévère
ces moyens là ils les retrouveront
ils restent aussi qu en attendant
au milieu des peuples
de tous les peuples qui portent chacun
son fardeau comme nous portons le nôtre
je crois que la nation française
est vraiment digne de la france mesdames
messieurs je vous remercie et j'ai
terminé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]